hey guys it's Johanna here when the
weather is hot I like my meals to be
light fresh and easy to digest so this
is the best time to enjoy a bowl of
refreshing salad for your lunch and
dinner - some of you salad might seem
like the boring or blood option if
that's the case it's because you're not
making a salad right my salad will be
packed full of tasty ingredients
different varieties and textures and the
best part is you can make it the day
before and bring it with you to work or
school plus if you're watching your
weight you will know exactly what you've
put in it so the tip to make a healthy
balanced and delicious salad is simply
grab a large bowl and combine one
portion of carbs one portion of protein
lots of fresh vegetables and fruits a
selection of herbs or sprinkles and
light salad dressing please read my
description box below for a list of
examples so my cell recipes are super
quick easy and they make very filling
meals if you like rice it just like me
then my chicken and then go salad is for
you the ingredients you need are 1 cup
of rice cooked and cool leftover rice is
perfect for this 6 ounces of shredded
chicken breasts cooked and cool choose
to grill bake on lightly pan fry the
chicken breasts for vegetarian you may
replace this with 1 can of beans of your
choice 1/2 a medium mango peeled and
diced into small cubes 1/2 a medium
cucumber dies into small cubes 1 medium
green onion thinly sliced 1 tablespoon
of basil leaves roughly chopped and salt
and pepper to taste as for the dressing
juice from one lime 1/2 a tbsp of sesame
oil 1/2 a tablespoon of rice vinegar and
half a tablespoon
honey let's start by making the salad
dressing in a small bowl combine juice
from one lime rice vinegar sesame oil
and honey set it aside then in a large
bowl combine the rice chicken breast
cucumber mango and green onion mix it
well then let you toss all the
ingredients with the salad dressing and
don't forget to season with salt and
pepper finally sprinkle the basil leaves
and serve so you're getting your carbs
from the rice protein from the chicken
breast crunchy texture from the cucumber
sweetness from the mango freshness from
the basil leaves and topped with an
asian-inspired salad dressing this huge
bowl only has three hundred and thirty
eight point five calories you may choose
to replace the rice with couscous quinoa
pasta or potatoes when salad is as
hearty healthy and delicious as this it
is hard not to love it
my next favorite is spiced chickpeas
tuna salad the ingredients you need are
one can of chickpeas rinsed and drain or
any other beans of your choice
one can of tuna drained and flake for
vegetarians you may omit this one medium
bell pepper diced into small cubes
quarter of a medium red onion finely
diced 2 cups of any fresh leafy greens
half of a medium avocado dies into small
cubes and 1 tablespoon of basil leaves
chopped as for the dressing juice from
half a lemon one teaspoon of paprika 1
teaspoon of rice vinegar and salt and
pepper to taste again let's start by
making the salad dressing in a bowl
combine juice from half a lemon paprika
rice vinegar salt and pepper
set it aside then in a large bowl
combine chickpeas tuna bell pepper red
onion and avocado mix it well then
lightly toss all the ingredients with
the salad dressing serve it over the
leafy greens and finally sprinkle with
basil leaves this bowl of salad on its
own is under 200 calories per serving
you can choose to have it just on its
own or serve it with a side of pita
bread come to TIA or wrap which will
definitely keep you satisfied for a long
time this salad is full of texture and
flavor you're getting the sweetness and
crunchiness from the bell pepper red
onion and leafy green balance with the
creaminess from the avocado this is then
topped with a very light salad dressing
most of the time seller on its own make
a very light and healthy meal however if
it's topped with creamy dressing which
is very high in calories it can turn
into an unhealthy meal so choose your
salad dressing wisely and serve in
moderation these are just two of my
favorite summer salads try them out make
your own combination and share your
pictures with me on Facebook and
Instagram all the best for new Fitness
food and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my You Tube
channel and website do follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
you